hey amber yo um before we get started do
you have any news you want to share i do
the amber ruffin show just got renewed
for season two
[Applause]
you didn't think you were gonna get two
episodes but you got
two
now you got a bunch of reasons see amber
ruffin
amber often says
[Applause]
you tell me who you gonna watch his
amber robin
come on
[Applause]
and tara davis comes on the border here
we go everybody we thank the lord we're
gonna do this yeah we'll be so long come
on let everybody have a ball we're about
to do it let's all right i must
you guys
y'all guys yeah i don't know what you
did but i did it
[Applause]
this show for good there's a there's a
dude and a spider-man like sweater and
he was
hey
[Applause]
you better get on that song clap we need
you spidey
um tonight is our last episode of season
one and then we'll be back on october
8th to start our brand new season i am
so excited and tarik is too you can just
tell from the expression on his face
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
well heaven is like choke
after that
according to a new poll 63 percent of
americans believe employees should
receive paid time off to get the
coronavirus vaccine said amazon workers
paid time what now
new research has shown that after an
asteroid wiped out 76 of plants and
animals on earth snakes were able to
thrive and some of them even got elected
to congress
[Applause]
she really stuck it to congress yeah
i'm not a snake no no my skin
actor leonardo dicaprio recently
purchased a new 13 million home in
malibu he'll hold on to it until it
reaches 25 million then dump it
you think we don't know what you're
doing over here
yeah we see you we see you
catch me if you can
what's eating gilbert group
let me you know what let me just
nothing good happens when those
spectacles come out
former
performer first lady melania trump is
facing criticism after a new book
reported that she fell asleep early on
election night 2020 and had to be woken
up before president trump's remarks
which brings us to a new segment we call
there are so many other things
[Music]
bingo
this woman took a nap this is not news
there are so many other things y'all
melania sucks remember when she
plagiarized michelle obama at the rnc
that sucked remember that coat she wore
to the border
that sucked too
oh remember when she stood by her
fascist racist husband for four years
while he tanked the entire country
that sucked so much but you know what
doesn't suck naps
naps are not bad naps are in fact the
best there are so many other things the
world is on fire everybody is dying
democracy is falling apart we cannot
start vilifying naps we just can't
afford it
even if the people taking the naps are
garbage necks are the only thing this
lady and i can agree on so
do not blame the naps because eventually
you're gonna need one too
you wanna know why because there are so
many other things
[Music]
social media app tick tock announced a
new feature this week to help support
users mental health it's called
uninstall
this week was rapper nas's 48th birthday
and if you're still thinking of a gift
all he needs is one mic
it's not for all of you
but the people for whom it is do enjoy
themselves
a hospital in upstate new york announced
that it will stop delivering babies
after several employees refused to get
the vaccine
which is probably for the best because
they're the same nurses who think that
the baby comes out the butt
and finally world afro day was this week
which day take your pick
[Applause]
i don't
i don't know why not and that was the
monologue did you like it
okay
good
because
that monologue is the only monologue we
wrote and now it's time for a segment
from my good friend tarik tarik take it
away
hello everyone and welcome to taric
sports minute where we cover all the
news and sports in just one minute whoa
whoa whoa
uh what's up this segment is just about
sports
yep and it's gonna last a full minute
like 60 whole seconds
that's right no no uh shut it down we do
not have an entire minute to devote to
sports on this show but what about all
our fans who want to hear us talk about
sports they do not exist
well
what about that guy
oh i'm just a fan of the color red
hey hey do something from cats see
how would you even fill a whole minute
with sports what would you even talk
about
we were talking about the standing
standings
what
or the brackets bra cuts what are you
even saying
maybe like the highlights highlights
derek the only highlights we talk about
on this show are frosted tips
like a tit pass what is a tipped pass
it's when a defensive lineman breaks up
a play by getting handles stop you stop
it right now uh
i just i just thought maybe we could
change it up a little and you went with
sports
tarik we have 21 precious minutes to
cover some of the most important issues
facing our country and you want to spend
one of those minutes talking about
everybody who got their balls tipped no
sorry i'm not doing it
look to be completely honest i thought
this might happen you know which is why
i've already condensed taric's sports
minute into an even shorter even
snappier segment called tarik's
fantastic fantastic 15 seconds of sports
we can get in and out real quick
please
fine 15 seconds but that's it
that's all i need roll it andre
football bad
good
good but also bad
nope
no no no no no no no we don't know no
tennis
queen
king
king who's also a queen
nba hall of fame usa hall of shame
carrick davis is my name
whoa
come on
come on
yeah baby
come on
that is fantastic 15 seconds of sports
what y'all know about that
[Applause]
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
[Music]
you